You feel like there's more you could do
on a personal element to take away from
the drama that everyone is
getting benefited more productive
things.  Muslim for each other of these
things and everyone's making like I see
last week he made some big remarks about
the next was all incorrect.
I don't mention my name
but man is now sending online courses
he's going to show me to be a millionaire
like the game is gone and I'm saying to
you because the right now
you're saying I say when it comes
to issues
between we have to look into it like
personal issues
are we have our own arrogance our
own you know you get show man you
know when he saw two people
fighting fighting rocks
[Music]
angest
man
how
meally compare myself
people me something I go I fight but
I'm looking
back I'm saying
back Allah so now I look to my situation
with the people I'm going to deal with
him in a way that I'm try my best to do
something to please Allah not to please
my so if personal issues I should try
myself as a stay away from it but if
issue which is based upon
is to
tr us the tr by advising first adv him
even adv him upon trying to spread
misgidance and innovations then we have
to openly refute him for the sake of
protection  Islam you know Islam came to
protect five things Islam came to
protect five things one of them Islam
came the first all Islam came to protect
the religion Islam
the protect the Muslim.
Muslim trying to corrupt de which take
presidence protecting the
deer because
the benit of the people take residence
over the benefit of
individual so that's why you look back
any people
if you
mention you sit together and you have
open conversation discussion not so much
angle where I'm coming to you for deing
to
exchange and propose our positions
and how we got here because I understand
that there element of this debate has been
happening for centuries but at the same
time there has to be some kind of like
because I feel like  it's better for the
Muslims if the Muslims of today we saw
last two years Muslim done I don't want
to say the word but nothing for the
people of Palestine so far weve seen
that nothing we can easily we can easily
squash Israel not
Where do we get weapons from all
Americans?  So how can we fight how can
you fight people weapon from because you
pay engineer you forget
that's what I'm saying so you
have to start from the beginning you see
and now look even you straight away with
Saudi but Saudi is not the strongest
army in the world Pakistan is one of them
and Pakistan is
responsible because there's no
[Music]
Algeria
village against another village village
Muslims and village was believer so the
Muslim they were winning they were
winning
drink water from it and go fight and
win.  Once they started getting defeated the
second time they got defeated the first
time they got defeated so the mus in
hung we used to win where we got
defeated so some people said the reason
be we getting defeated there are some
Muslims are throwing dirt and impurity
in the river that which we used to go
and drink to get stronger you with me
and
so listen before we go fight another
people let us rectify that river
God us
through the victory coming from it.  So
should we carry fighting even though we
clearly got defeated or we should
rectify and clean the water the river
that we getting the power from we should
clean the water
first gave about the Quran.  Before we
go fight our enemies outside, we have
to rectify our problems with you. You can go
clean the house outside when you have
inside making it dirty because if
someone comes to attack you, you have to hide
behind your house. Your house is like a fortress; you already have
enemies inside. So,
like Allah, the Quran, Allah will never
give us a victory until we teach Allah to our abilities. Of course, we are perfect, but when we have, I have to be straight with you. Respected. Praise be to Allah. Associating partners with Allah, if there is any bloodshed for me, no, you can't because of what I'm saying, because some Muslims
follow this teaching. [Music
]
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. Abdul
Jilani, by
Allah, Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him.
Was
coming,
stop.
Allah, you seek help from your Lord, and He answers you.
Allah will for less than He will, so Abu,
and you think so without any. Let
me
ask Ahmed, my brother, Ahmed, my
brother,
Allah, glory be to Him,
and then
350.
Allah, I asked them, He created the heavens and the earth.
Allah, they are polytheists. Allah and those who take
protectors besides Him, we do not worship them except that they may bring us closer to
[Music]
Allah,
independent, which do now, do they use, and
I know I don't.  I don't know very much,
but I know that
enough, yeah. But I was going to ask a few
questions after seeing how
this works now, in terms of asking.
We know he's going to be our
intercessor, that's a good point. Before I come, let me explain the point. So the point is, the first thing is,
even though they believe in
Allah speaking, "Call upon Me, I will respond to
you." Allah, the Exalted, peace and blessings be upon him. Allah, intercession belongs to
Allah
alone.
Allah, intercede for
your Messenger Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him.
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. The line of polytheism is
very delicate. The line is,
for example, when I was a Sufi, I had my uncles, scholars, explain why
we have to go through
people. They understand, so excuse me, I was doing it.
Not everyone who falls into disbelief falls into disbelief
[laughs] at
him. Before someone...
and when you understand the polytheism of Allah
and you look at what happened, some doing the
same thing, the Muslims
believe in Allah, but they use to
ask Allah to forgive
me. I'm going to take
this...  straight instant respse so don't
judge
me I don't see why it is impossible because
the way I'm seeing
ofation with
Allah you know you are
making as no what I'm looking as the
using crutch is ass you not as a
tool to a tool for delivery
Yeah.  How do you phone?  Imagine I'm here
standing there nothing and I come pick
me up and is not even around that's me that's
me if I don't if Jam is u driver
in this
analysis if the u driver is not here and
there's no other tool that I use for the
Uber to hear me there's nothing I can
use is in bush bush market and uB can
pick me up what you think about me
saying
this God bless you because
all you believe can hear you not here I
believe I don't know about that I'm not
going  to speak on
that points that you going to bring the
point I was going to make is this point
I was going to make is I know from like
some basic research in science the human
sense is very limited so even you and me
we're standing around we see all these
things around us but our eye Allah made
it so we only see very smooth amount
that's true.  Limited so the same way I
can't hear dogs whistle.  Yes.  So the
same way I can't hear things that are
going on right now and I can't see
things that are taking place.
I can't rule out the possibility that
there is maybe angel here.
Allah, did you take? Who
answers the distressed when he calls upon Him?
[Laughs]
Allah, Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him,
they ask you about the ocean. Say, they ask you about the
new moons.
The supplication is to Allah. And when My servants ask you about Me, He is
near. Allah, the Exalted, and the following does
n't want to. The Prophet, peace and
blessings be upon him, Abdullah bin
Abbas, O boy, if you ask, then ask Allah, and if you seek help, then seek help from Allah. Hari
bin
Khattab bin Khattab, may Allah be pleased with him and grant him His pleasure. Abbas, Abbas,
Abbas. To be alive, we used to ask him to pray for us or do the prayer. Now you do it. Now we know if asking the Prophet for asking all the time
is not
who the more understanding of the
Prophet and go
to understand.
Yes.
[Laughter]
Muhammad, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him
[Laughter] And
peace be upon him underst
langs and our Arabic language all the language of the communicate but maybe Arabic but anyway
he didn’t understand
Spanish French after passed away now
understand language the one who understands every language
and the one who knows who can
hear everything at the
same
time who has everything at the same time
so
fight
something, I swear to God, it will sect
you, I swear to God,
teacher now,
God bless the Jannah,
Algeria learn
noticed
me in because my father dream my
grandmother dream  me this the book it
when I read it Allah said prophet
Muhammad
said my family back
[Music]
Me on Wednesday at seven o'clock
religious understanding I wanted a
historical understanding like academic
understanding like completely objective
not from the not from not from
not from anyone just from I want to
see what the research is on the
histor put
regarding
abdes and he wrote a book against his
brother and
he and theory
estudi of Islamic and Empire and some
battles that took place where Muslim
lives was killed.
GC GP
Jesus
things
was program to the
point by
his father
[laughter]
Scholars in Iraq
granted permission to the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
Abdul
Wahhab, the
methodology,
God, the Book of
Tawhid,
Hadiths, Praise be to God, the Giver, Praise be to God, Praise be to God, Praise be to God, had no desert, however they own rulers,
some rulers [
music]
Ottoman Abdul
Wahhab, let
us use many,
his age, excuse me
[music]
Tawhid, Muhammad Pasha,
King, Imam Abdul Aziz bin Saud, may God have mercy on him, Praise be to God, the office of you know, some made up, some made up, you know there is an article that was made up by the
empire in
India, British accusation that was working
for the British, and let us use analyze that this logically, Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, British,
I don't think they
do resources and the human neighbor, Ash'ari, Ash'ari, and this is Ash'ari, Ash'ari,
Muhammad Abdul Wahhab
[music]
Abdul
Wahhab,
occit
inv
thatlsight occ, British.  No, what saying
makes sense.  But what I'm saying is last
week I heard what a Pakistani official
said from um the government and he said
we've been getting millions from Britain
and America to create certain
organizations basically terrorist
organizations in our country to house
these people and to groom them because
this creates a space for
war by the west
100% was 30 years ago. Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton
[Music]
God bless the people of
Saudi Arabia, God willing, God bless the people of
Saudi Arabia,
my love, even people forgive me forgive me
if I'm wrong genuinely believe that
people is allowed to stand and spread
what they spread 100% and everyone for
many years around him is getting
radicalized for 20 years that story 100%
this yeah all these people and they
don't realize the people around them
don't realize they're sincere but
because they're misguided because  they
got the ban of salf and Quran sunah and
they can misrepresent certain themes in
Islam and a young mind it's easy for
this like what's the excited you know
like you said previously arrogant what
these
tra may put into the mi before you know
it a lot of these taken and you created
a new like people getting killed for no
reason and now is gettinged in the media
again right so i think all these organ
is a drip feeding process
right the point i was making the biger
point was at the time i feel like  the agenda
suited the west because you cannot be
because why at that time the west agenda
Ahmadi
Hadith Abdul
Wahhab,
the scholars of
Hadith, Abdul Hamid Abdul Hamid, Imam Abdul
Hamid, Al-Bashir Al-Ibrahimi, the
Salafist movement, Abdul Wahhab,
Algeria, did they build schools,
education, when the Algerian revolution in
the year of November
1954 of the French, he said this
revolution was started by Abdul Hamid,
even though Abdul Hamid died nearly 15
years before, Salafism,
Salafism, Abdul
Wahhab, agenda
of Imam Osama
Uthaymeen, Sheikh Al-Albani, Sheikh Fawzan, Khadi
Khouya, Algeria, Algeria, Ben, Algeria,
extremia was, Al-Madina, Fawzan,
Schop in the mountain
for those influenced by, to know the school, they bring
you there, spreading it,
and he said, the Algerian general, he said, look, I'm
speaking, beh, the Algerian
president at that time,
Yoube, the mountain, killing wrong,
and you agree on
things to bring back,
Tawhid, Tawhid, my
brother,
Shirk
[laughter],
Allah, the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, Ibrahim,
and when I am sick, it is He who cures me, Ibrahim, peace be upon him,
Allah
[laughter]
[laughter],
Ibrahim, Ibrahim,
Ibrahim, ask,
because
people
about, as concern, they are doing, is with the, of, is,
or  we can get to that many that's why
i told you there is an excuse for some of
them
of mean they misunderstood or verse or a
village
there in
Algeria
was because of the entation
of the
[laughter]
of you
people seeking from the french
government Algeria doesn't make any
sense and that's what people
do
MJ Palestinian to go to Palestine def
country he's in America
travel travel
May God protect you, my love, may God protect you, thank you
I
don't
care
for people audience people
[music]
listening people that make on me
people to be people to
infidel my
brother is a halal infidel
[laughter] my
brother before these guys
eat they face so now you can behave like a
country
[music]
abominations expos
They don't know they serve western
back agenda based interest capism you
know these
[music]
things people who are sincere in their
intention correct
right but even guided yes clearly
because they feel innocent they feel
like they are following the correct teaching
correct that's why me make something clear
I  don't believe every person that went
with ISIS
I believe I some they
[Music]
intelpress have to be saying I believe   I
feel
like is very localized understanding of
Islam to specific region of the world
you feel like worldwide by that it has
no logical or historical appeal so it to
the emotions and sentiments of people of
a certain areas are the world IR may
Syria some in Pakistan but there's not
many
other
Somalia is what is
for reason why people
are
right they
can go
back
the right
got a good book a good and I appreciate
a lot of how he has understanding of
Allah never heard Allah is explained in
man before besides of his own words but
how he speaks to the modern  mind of today's
world
not
today is much better than the
advice of the savior  The Holy Misguidance.
He wrote it to advise one of his students,
and that book, when I read it, was
unbelievable. But also, you think, so yeah, you know why? If you read his words, you know he doubted himself, his senses. He had awakening, realization, awakening, yeah, but he was awakening. He wasn't the Quran, the Sunnah, the Sunnah,
wake him up. You
see, I'm saying that's the outcome of
so.
[Music]
Ghazali, Al-Qurtubi, the
Arab, the
Arab, Al-Ghazali
[Laughter] Creed, Methodology, Spec of Offices.
I feel like he's a bit of a
character,
but I'm saying it because he's got a
bounded experience, different things.
When he's finally coming to look at the de, his understanding
is more enriched than a
lot of people who specialized as purely academics.
I don't know about what I read
from him; he's not the best person to read from. He was
heavily influenced by philosophy.
[Music]
Hadiths, Praise be to
God, Secrets of
Ahmad, the Sunnah, Imam Ahmad, Hanbali, Shaybani, Explanation of the Sunnah,
Imam Al-Barbahari, Explanation of the Sunnah, Imam Al-
Mazli, Principles of the Belief of the Sunnah, Imam
Al-Lalaka'i,
the Shi'a, the call, my brother, the Shi'a,
the Sirs, my beloved, God willing, my beloved, may God bless
you, may God bless you, God bless you,
what a
little